real quick I want to do a documentary
recommendation I recommend that you a
while ago this movie called Somme about
wine sommelier 'z and it was super
entertaining in its eccentricity and and
pretension and there's the sort of
sequel now called Somme into the bottle
which follows some of the same Psalms
but also brings in some new ones I'm
fascinated by this world Pat I'm not a
big wine drinker at all but I am
fascinated by the world of Sommeliers
and the documentary is really well done
have you seen the first one the first
some no I honestly have not it's good I
recommend it and I don't know if you're
a big wine guy or not I'm really not I
met someone in in Italy on my trip about
a month ago who knows a lot of the
Psalms in these two documentaries and
she she had some colorful comments to
make about them and I just find the
entire world of it interesting and when
I was in Las Vegas last week at one of
the restaurants we went to there was a
psalm and nice guy came over made some
recommendations on wine etc and after
our sort of host ordered a couple
bottles of wine he came over multiple
times offering more bottles of wine even
after our host said I think we're all
good and generally you know these Psalms
are supposed to be the height of
politeness and manners and continually a
more and more aggressively offering wine
and then after it became clear we
weren't ordering any more bottles
started going around to different people
at the table with the menu of glasses
that were available and it was like the
most aggressive pitch I've ever seen
from a some anywhere at any restaurant
that I've been to but that's really the
exception I mean generally we're talking
about professionals who are actually the
height of politeness and and decorum but
you will see a lot of this world if you
watch the documentary Psalm into the
bottle it is on Netflix it's on Amazon
and you can find it along with all of my
other recommendations at david
pakman.com slash recommendations